we are honored to accept this award and  we would first like to thank the academy  and the scitec committee the walt disney  animation  studios hair simulation system has been  in  constant development since 2005 and we  would like to thank the many people who  have contributed  to its evolution over the years  including the technology engineers  the technical directors the artists and  research collaborators  we would like to also acknowledge the  production and the leadership of walt  disney animation studios  for embracing technical challenges head  on and making the space for the  developers to work to meet those  challenges  most importantly we want to recognize  the artists  who are not only our collaborators but  use  the tool set to craft the motion of the  hair on our films  and it is only when the technology is  coupled with their artistic genius that  the magic really happens  and we are privileged to get to work  with them every day  thank you